what's up guys bangbang lunch money time
Memorial Day special well Wall Street is
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our lunch money right I'm
here with the beautiful and intelligent
Polina Mayer Innova we just had a fight
before this don't let this fool you he
flicked me in the head she deserved to
be flicked but before we get into the
topics today as you can see in the
bottom right block by huge shout-out to
block fire we got a sponsor
aka get money get paid block fights
gonna be sponsoring the show for a while
now basically they've got three products
you can buy and sell cryptocurrency you
can give them crypto and they'll give
you a u.s. dollar alone or my favorite
product you can earn up to 8.6 percent
on an interest-bearing account you can
go in the description click on a link
we'll tell you more after the show but
huge shout out to block by the team
their investor I'm a user generally a
huge fan and now they're part of the
lunch money currents literally the only
thing he talks about so here we are
hey real recognize real Memorial Day
first topic what's up with a Memorial
Day today is Memorial Day what's that is
Memorial Day celebrated outside of the
United States Dena no no it's just a
u.s. thing what I don't like is that you
know everybody's like Memorial Day sale
and cookout and whatever and it's not
about sales Memorial Day is to honor the
people who have served this country uh
kind of it's actually it's actually to
celebrate the people who have died okay
yeah some where they basically know it
celebrates see this is that this is one
of the things that I think a lot of
people are mistake about Veterans if you
talk to most veterans they will say
there's no reason to like cry and and be
upset and like do all this stuff around
death right they're very unique view and
like my view of it is like if I died I
want people have a party like part of
your faces off celebrate life don't be
sad about me dying instead celebrate
life and I think that there's a lot of
people I think there's a lot of people
if you talk to them who are veterans
that's how
look at that and so I'm cool with the
celebrate knock yourself out but just
remember like you know there's some
people who did some cool [ __ ] to to make
sure that we're all free and by the way
the rest of the world freedom comes at a
cost so you know we'll see what happens
freedom does come at a cost big cost
sometimes lots of lives all right
digital currency what's going on there
that's a--that's a pretty uh nondescript
topic writing there well so this is
interesting
so as the idea of central bank digital
currency starts to gain traction for spa
I didn't know it was gaining traction
but anyway the u.s. in particular needs
to pay attention or risk losing a major
aspect of I can talk of its geopolitical
power according the JPMorgan Chase what
do you think Anthony hey welcome to the
game JPMorgan Chase basically central
bank digital currency is simply taking a
digital currency we're taking a central
bank currency and digitizing it so again
most of you already know my belief is
that every currency is gonna be digital
since when is a gaining traction No
so there's three separate types of
digital currencies if you will one is a
separation of state and money which is
Bitcoin right so no sock no nation has
control or monetary policy
decision-making power the second is
something like a private corporation
which is what Facebook's Libre
originally was so a company could create
a currency and try to drive adoption and
then the third obviously is a central
bank currency which is what the US
dollar the yen the Euro all that stuff
is basically what's gonna happen here
every currency is going to be digital
right the difference is what they're
talking about is quote there's no
country with more to lose from the
disruptive potential digital currency
than the United States this revolves
primarily around the US dollar hegemony
issuing the global reserve currency in
the medium exchange for international
trade in commodities goods and services
conveys immense advantages end quote so
duh you having the US dollar via global
reserve currency gives the u.s. lots of
power but if you think about it there's
330 million people in the United States
compared to 7 point whatever billion in
the world it's a very small percentage
of people and then if you think about
who drives that US dollar monetary
policy it's like 12 people
while people who determine the global
reserve currency everything that happens
with that money for the world and so
what ends up happening is it's an
accessibility problem right so if you
think about how many people in Bulgaria
can get access to dollars actually not
that many right no they can't they go to
the bank will the bank give them dollars
if they change yeah some but not all
banks if they go to the ATM they can't
pull it out in dollars in many cases in
some makes they can and some they can't
so if you want dollars let's say that
tomorrow the Bulgarian love started to
fail right and it felt 50 per say yeah
but people would be like super worried
right and they'd want dollars and it's
hard to get dollars but if now all of a
sudden all I need is an internet
connection and I can get access to
dollars or yen or Euros or 1 or whatever
it is because they're all digital now I
start to choose well what's monetary
policy is actually the best one right
and so that's where I think Bitcoin will
win other people think the dollar will
win other people think other currencies
will win and so the whole idea is if you
digitize currencies you now bring
accessibility around the world it's an
equal playing field I'm kind of
surprised that currency hasn't already
been digitized well I think of it as
it's been it's an electronic now
technically it is digital and that it's
ones and zeros but when we talk about
digital currencies in this sense what
we're specifically talking about is the
ability where you don't need a US bank
right so right now if you want dollars
for the most part you have to have a
bank account but what happens when you
can just sign up for a coin base account
or for a by Nance account and you can
get access to all of these digital
currencies and you don't have to go
through kind of bureaucratic process or
the gatekeepers currencies would you own
Bitcoin I mean look to be complete on us
if you're in a place where your
currencies failed you want dollars right
there it's it's the strongest most
stable I'm kind of most believed in
global reserve currency in the world
right so obviously you want dollar so
let's take Venezuela Zimbabwe Lebanon
wherever but what they do is they put
capital controls in place they make it
really hard to get dollars are really
dangerous to get dollars and so they
what they want to do is they want to
lock you into their local currency but
now if every currency is just available
through the internet you know there was
an internet connection it changes the
whole game
so I think that's part of what you know
these guys are talking about and by the
way anytime there's disruption the
leader has the most
Lu's yeah right one time guys fun aside
I went with him to this panel that he
was on and he literally it was a very
uncomfortable panel to begin with but
you got in an argument with one of the
people in the audience remember over
digital currencies why the one where
they wouldn't let me in oh I don't want
to say what the organisation was but we
can just say that it was very heavy on
the suits and a lot of intellectual
people who thought they were geniuses
and they were saying ridiculous
ridiculous things like oh the US could
just buy all the Bitcoin I was like you
guys have no clue you're talking I
almost didn't it wasn't an argument it
was I almost didn't get wedding to fight
I wasn't wearing a suit yeah actually
legitimately legitimately I had plana
and Joe who helps us with the show with
me and they they tried to not let them
in and so I basically was like cool if
you don't want them in I'm not coming
yeah it was a little showdown floor
showdown at the front door you know wake
him up let him know I'm serious I mean
business get money get paid what's going
on at Hong Kong were you wearing a suit
no Hong Kong oh my god the protests are
getting crazy are they getting crazy
yeah if I was in Hong Kong and I was I
was in native Hong Kong I think is their
language
I've been going wild why because you're
supposed to be a separate sovereign land
well you're supposed to be a lot of
things but what China China is not
letting the crisis go to waste
China thinks that they're just going to
pass laws and take over Hong Kong take
away the sovereignty be able to take
people quelling protests teargas baton
charges water cannons so the whole idea
here is that for those that don't know
Hong Kong previously was under British
control for long period of time is
basically got handed back but under the
promise that Hong Kong would remain
independent from mainland China over the
last I think year year and a half China
has tried multiple times to pass certain
laws that make it appear like Hong Kong
is still independent
but would be really fall under Chinese
rule so things like any Hong Kong
citizen could be taken and brought back
to China if they break a law right the
trial / trial for like all these things
right and so they've tried to pass
another law there's a video that went
viral on the internet recently we're
literally in the Hong Kong lawmakers
facility or whatever you call it
they literally picked up people who are
pro-democracy lawmakers and elected
officials who are pro-democracy they
picked them up and they carried them out
they dragged them out
close the doors locks them the people
are banging on the door trying to get in
and they held a vote they just took away
the opposition it would be like in the
House of Representatives if we went in
and said you know what there's 20
representatives who don't agree with
this law and we want to get it passed so
you know what let's just let's just pick
them up and take them out right let's
pick up the who's the oldest frailest
ones who we can just get out of here and
the motors hold them outside close the
doors we'll hold the boat without them
and then it gets past the crazy guys so
long story short is this is incredibly
sad I am so glad that we have the
internet though because the internet
democratizes the access to this
information and now there are people who
are protesters in Hong Kong who simply
can turn on their phones and get the
information out and we're seeing what's
happening right and it's sad I mean yeah
and it is happening in the time where
you know after the corona virus now
people are you know holding these
protests obviously well they're even
wearing masks yeah of course well the
whole idea is look government's been
doing this forever right you basically
wait till the will of the people is
broken and then you try to step in and
you can do it one or two ways you can
step in and say like hey I'm from the
government not here to help you right
because your will is broken I'm willing
to give you money whatever and make you
more addicted to my support and you move
away from capitalism order like a social
society or you can do what they're doing
which is literally we have guns and
we're gonna do whatever we want to do
and so like here's my message to the
people Hong Kong rage on like stand up
for what you believe in
and that's what they're doing and so you
just gotta sit from far away and say
look I'm not an expert on this stuff I
don't understand all of the nuances
right I've never been to mainland China
therefore in the whole idea is just like
let them stand up for what they believe
it right
that is what democracy is about and
we've talked about Memorial Day to start
with the whole idea is that everyone
should have a voice even the people that
you don't agree with right that's the
beauty of America is you and I can
disagree on something but I can respect
the fact that you have the freedom of
speech to talk about it yeah right we do
we disagree a lot you know I usually end
up being right but it's fine
speaking of being right 3d printing
what's going on there
okay wait can I segue for a second can I
take a hard detour I just want to bring
up something I've been thinking about a
lot this is an iced coffee and there's a
lot of people are gonna start ordering
lots of iced coffee over the summer
because it's hot out in they want ice
and coffee but you're not a real ice
coffee drinker unless you drink it
during the winter I always get iced
coffee no matter what iced coffee
cold outside iced coffee hot outside
iced coffee snowing iced coffee
but if you didn't drink the iced coffees
during the winter you shouldn't be a lot
of drinking during the summer you should
be allowed to drink but iced coffee
drinkers are just like you know we have
a certain set of pride when it's you
know 13 degrees outside it's snowing and
you walk in and you said oh let me get a
large iced coffee I'm gonna something
good about that I'm gonna exercise my
first know my right of freedom of speech
whatever to say that iced coffee is just
coffee that's pretending to be coffee
with just water and it's super like
diluted and it's gross hmm I knew that
she was a psychopath but that is like
it's true it's just grass that's grounds
for expulsion from the show like
literally this does not even look like
coffee it looks like brown that's what
life looks like with milk in it all
right
3d printing let's guys 3d printing is in
the valley of despair people aren't
printing in 3d anymore so basically the
whole idea here is that industry's kind
of go through these boom and bust cycles
right people get really excited then
they aren't as excited about it and
Cathy would shout out Cathy wood from
arc invest she's one of my favorite
investors if not my favorite on Wall
Street her
thing is that she went on CNBC recently
and she said look I believe that 3d
printing which has fallen out of favor
in recent years is going to have a
resurgence the general idea here is if
you're gonna bring manufacturing back
from overseas back to the United States
the u.s. does not have low enough labour
cost to just go out and hire a bunch of
people and so what you're gonna have to
do is you have to use machinery to do
that or you're gonna use technology
innovation to drive a manufacturing and
a supply chain revolution back in the
United States 3d printing will be a
massive piece and so her whole idea here
is that yes it might not be hot right
now but it's about to get super hot as
an investor you want to find things
before they become hot again that's what
she's trying to do so 3d printing can be
used to print artificial hips knees
hearing aids all that kind of that's all
the medical stuff again you can print
houses right but what are we in its
current form what are we using 3d
printing for it's being used for all the
stuff literally they're 3d printing
homes they're 3d printing medical
devices they're any type of plastics
like people are 3d printing guns all
that stuff can be why is it in the
valley of despair I feel like that's a
lot of applications so the whole idea is
that investor sentiment is not as high
as it used to be right but the amount of
work that's being done there it has to
remain consistent and grown but what
they're talking about is things like the
stock prices of companies that are big
in 3d printing are down investors have
kind of gone on to other technologies
that they think are more sexy you know
or exciting but what ends up happening
is just because inventor investor
sentiment goes down doesn't mean that
the actual value that the industry's
creating changes and so now all the
sudden they're about to turn back like
oh 3d printing right and then you get
the sentiment change back to positive
and that's where stock prices etc all
all rocks yeah makes sense absolutely I
think 3d printing is quite sexy what's
going on coronavirus things speaking of
sexy kids watch this show yeah two years
bang bang so okay so coronavirus dating
online dating is rapidly changing to
adapt to this new climate that we're in
they're zoom there's FaceTime I recently
found out that there was a zoom
Bachelorette
so there was a girl she'll my friend
she'll monnet not really my friend but I
know him he's a nice guy I'm big was he
the bachelor right or was he a
participant well he's the one that all
of the girls are supposed to try to like
swim
wait he's a bachelor he's the bachelor
Oh was it a second season yeah oh wow
well raising money for charity okay well
to be fair I will say as somebody who
has previously watched the show The
Bachelor in The Bachelorette
I think doing it over zoom in your home
might actually tell you a lot more about
the person then doing it in this like
fancy la home with all these glitzy
dresses and fake personalities it's kind
of like that [ __ ] tans the show that we
watched on Netflix what was the one
where they sat in the room love is blind
yeah that one was interesting what do
you think oh I thought it was very
interesting to see how it played out it
was very dramatic dramatic eyes drama
traumatized we're gonna have a highlight
clip with all the words I can't say but
yeah I mean look I personally am just
very excited that I have the love of my
life here with me every day I don't have
to worry about coronavirus even likes me
yeah I did flick you in the head but
look at what somebody said I have
literally four dates planned tonight
there's no dealing with the logistics
who's gonna split the bill are you gonna
kiss me after the date there's so many
different things that are very
distracting but I will say on the flip
side I would love to know if there's
somebody who refuses to pay the billed
end of the night like those little
things tell you so much about a person
do you member one time I almost broke up
with you because I thought you were
being mean to a weight not a waiter a
bartender and then the facts came out
and I was actually being overly kind
yeah I remember that day it's like it
replays every so often where you think
something and then I end up being right
okay speaking of what's good a
masterclass
assault assault okay wait masterclass
that's what it says here what's going on
master class they raise money you didn't
include the links a hundred million
dollars are you not a huge fan of
masterclass I love Y I just so I enjoy
all the different
types of classes there's RuPaul there's
Sara Blakely there's um you know all
these writers that I didn't do it what
is the structure of the classes for
those that don't know okay so you go in
and then there's like eight to 15 minute
video classes and after that there's a
workbook you can chat with other people
who are also watching the class you can
like download materials but it's just
very helpful I like hearing from
different people would you say that you
have learned more from master class
Twitter or me what do you want me to say
know what would be what would you really
say like it like stack rank is master
class as helpful as you think no say you
Twitter and master class if I'm being
honest but that's only because you're in
my face every day master class is not
alright I'm a big fan of master class I
thought I was really cool I watched two
of them I think right I watched the Bob
Iger 'two I know I watched most of it is
because I was tired Nike was boring and
then Sara Blakely one two I overheard
you listening to her I was very good
yeah she's smart all right one minute
and three seconds left lunch money time
who is this Jeff CC 20 dang stir tweet
so you picked this one you want to talk
about it yeah I asked you guys last week
use hashtag plan to start tell me what
she does it's annoying and Jeff hit you
know if he literally typed up a
ten-point list and tweeted it and it
says bang bang top ten annoying things
Polina does one not sticking to the
dress code to trying to bait pop that's
right men out there you know there's
bait you just step around it don't take
the bait number three rules arise in all
the hilarious jokes cuz they're
hilarious for constantly losing in
backgammon and chest murder see murder
scene every night we have game name five
don't listen to read or watch anything
about barstool yeah that one's probably
not true six in currently correcting pop
on his superior vocabulary hey you know
what I like this already this probably
why I chose this one seven doesn't like
the dead cat
you literally said presip it's the other
day you try to tell me you didn't say it
and then we rewind at the tape and you
said it I love everything being filmed
don't let facts get in the way of a good
story I don't know you're talking about
eight not letting the immaculate pomp
cut her hair we did not get to the 10000
yet were about four thousand favorites
we'll get there soon 9 she does
Bulgarian math she actually does do
Bulgarian math but the secret is
Americans Bulgarians are better than us
it's really funny I don't know why and
my friend who's from Mexico also does
this so I think it's a trend so I think
in English I do everything in English
except when I count in my head from like
one to ten or whatever or 20 or 100 I
just count in Bulgarian it's really
weird and I think it's probably cuz
that's like one of the first things you
learn as a kid what is the Bulgarian
word for a hundred stop stop
see why I gotta make it so easy over
there that's why you guys are good at
math like 100 is so many syllables you
guys got one syllable all right and then
the last one she's trying to do a
hostile takeover of the show literally
you're like a bandit yeah you're trying
to take over the show sorry but not
sorry plan I gotta get my lunch money
well Jeff you're getting the lunch money
man you're getting the lunch money and
he used Polina the star as the hashtag I
mean he did everything right suppose
your name rate to which is a lot of you
guys in the comments I realize plain his
name is well Pete Oh L ima not yeah okay
sorry
we're making progress that's it for
lunch money today Monday Memorial Day
special loss he's trying to get rich the
rest of us are just trying to get our
lunch money right we will see you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina
they've got 3 products they can give you
a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies
they're crypto exchanged I personally
use the interest-bearing account there's
not very many places where you'll find
up to 8.6 percent interest on a deposit
in an interest-bearing account go do
your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6 percent it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks that
block buy subscribe to our channel like
the video annoy plan in the comment and
we'll see you guys tomorrow and be kind
to your friends